the fourth of July is right around the
corner and what is more America than a
movie showing Washington DC getting
completely butt-fucked White House down
so White House down is the second White
House invasion holy [ __ ] Washington DC's
under attack by bad guys movie to come
out in 2013
this one's directed by Roland Emmerich
he's brought us independence day'
godzilla' day-after-tomorrow 2012 to
name a few yeah elephant in the room so
I'm gonna address it White House down is
the same premise of Olympus has fallen
so I'm going to compare a couple things
but I'm not going to get too obnoxious
about it in White House down our main
protagonist is Channing Tatum this
likable guy who's having father/daughter
issues with his daughter who's a little
kid who crawled out of the pit in the
Dark Knight Rises he wants to be a
Secret Service agent but he doesn't
quite have what it takes he has untapped
potential so Secret Service maverick
goes to the White House with his
daughter not that particular day he's
told not you're not going to be a Secret
Service agent however all these bad
dudes are gonna invade the White House
giving Channing Tatum the perfect
opportunity to prove what he's worth
Jamie Foxx was the president in this
movie I like Jamie Foxx is the president
you got this young well-spoken good
talking president guy okay he's likable
don't know much about him don't know if
I'd vote for him but I have no reason to
not vote for him dude wears sneakers
with his suit you know right there let's
vote worthy then we have ourselves a
roland emmerich movie roland emmerich
movies they're entertaining but a lot of
them suffer from the same thing is that
they're just bloated I was looking
through Roland Emmerich's filmography
most of them can have 20 to 30 minutes
shaved right off the set up in his
movies Channing Tatum's bring his
daughter to the White House for bring
your daughter to work day or some [ __ ]
oh here comes a comparison take Olympus
has fallen for example the beginning of
the movie has this death that happens
that affects the lives of two of the
main characters that sticks with you and
that's interesting and that's going to
keep you warm until the [ __ ] really hits
the fan later on this movie doesn't have
anything like that to get you engaged
with the characters there's no debt
there's no tragedy there's just
father/daughter issues that they talk
about while they're driving a car and
you're like yeah right that's not the
same and yeah the natural defense for
this is well those are character
building moments but they're not really
don't mistake boring scenes with
character development you can do
character development have it done
interesting to keep you engaged with the
characters or at least get you to
initially care about the characters and
you can do that all the dialogue if you
but just don't make it boring roland
emmerich movies generally speaking just
make it uninteresting
hey matthew broderick that's cool that
you had an ex-girlfriend in college or
whatever but we really came for Godzilla
I thought Jamie Foxx and Channing Tatum
worked really well together they were
good so it's not the performances that
are bad it's just the directing and the
writing and every character in this
movie has their cartoony moments it'd be
one thing if you had a couple of
characters that were comic relief but
the rest of everyone else is still
grounded in reality but everyone in this
movie has a cartoony moment or two long
drawn out set up and cartoony villains
don't really mix they're just
conflicting messages within a movie that
makes you go what am I watching
who made this movie is that weird
Michael Bay humor that Roland Emmerich
has also really like it just takes you
out of it you're like none of it is
grounded in reality at that point you
need an anchor in a movie like this no
one's really an anchor so basically
white house down had boring dialogue
scenes that were supposed to be
character development scenes but it's
not what you came to see and you don't
care because the movie doesn't do a good
job at making you care because you don't
connect with the characters then the
shit's going down you're like I'm sorry
I didn't care before so I'm not gonna
care now the bullets are flying and some
of you be like but Jeremy you can still
take this movie as a mindless action
movie movie that's supposed to be a
mindless action movie shouldn't be any
deeper than a mindless action movie
they're supposed to be fine and that's
true but this movie isn't just a
mindless action movie it took a half an
hour in the beginning of this movie to
establish that this is going to be more
than a mindless fun action movie so
sadly you can't go back and rewind that
and undo its failed attempt at being
deeper than a fun mindless action movie
the movie can only press forward and be
what it really is a failed attempt at
being more than a fun mindless popcorn
action movie in the end for white house
down I want to say it's alright but
you're not gonna remember it in t-minus
a couple days yep already forgotten
right so Olympus has fallen or white
house down which one do you prefer I
want to see if some people prefer this
to Olympus has fallen whichever one you
prefer comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
you